[Music]
[Music]
thank you all for joining us in the
privilege of being present today to
celebrate this wonderful occasion in the
life of science and of MIT and certainly
of our friend and colleague bob horvitz
there is no event that more symbolizes
and reminds us of why we are all here
than when one of our colleagues wins the
highest possible accolade for the
science that he or she has done the
things that we do at MIT the things that
people especially like Bob do in basic
research in my view is at the absolute
highest level of human accomplishment
and it is truly a privilege to count Bob
among our friends and colleagues and to
recognize how he has advanced the state
of human knowledge and how that
knowledge ultimately will improve health
for humankind so thank you all for being
here and I would like now to ask our
colleague Phil sharp to introduce Bob
film
Thank You Chuck it's a great honor to be
asked to introduce Robert Horowitz and I
want to begin by congratulating Bob for
his outstanding research and work here
at MIT as a colleague
Bob's research as you will hear is
fundamental to all life processes
fundamental to how a multicellular
organism is formed fundamental to how
our brain is formed and works and
fundamental to the processes related
disease such as cancer and therefore as
you would expect bob has many homes he
is a professor in the Department of
Biology
he is an investigator in the McGovern
Institute for brain research and he is a
member of the Center for cancer research
here at MIT beyond the borders of MIT
bob has also other homes
he is a investigator in the Howard
Hughes Medical Institute and has been
supported by Howard Hughes for many
years in from the day he came to MIT
almost he has been supported by the
National Institute of Health so bob has
many friends and many homes now it has
been said that the best predictor of
whether you're going to receive a Nobel
Prize statistically is having your
office within 50 yards of another Nobel
Prize winner in Bob's case you want to
interpret that as mentors now bob was an
undergrad at MIT where he measured
majored in mathematics and economics and
his advisor here was Bob Solow
who if you don't know as a Nobel in
economics he went to Harvard and his
advisor at Harvard where he got his PhD
in biology was Jim Watson and Wally
Gilbert and that's three for three
and then he went to Cambridge to do a
postdoc and there things were getting a
little slow for him and keeping this
perfect record and his mentor at
Cambridge was Sydney Brenner and john
sulston Sydney was his postdoctoral
mentor John is who he worked with and
they share this honor with him this year
and that makes it five four five four
Bob so if he wants to be a postdoc in
somebody's lab around here I'm sure the
others with would accept him bob has
been at MIT for many years since I think
76 or something like that he not only
has done outstanding research but he has
been a wonderful colleague he teaches he
teaches remarkably well as you will
learn and enthusiastically and he has
trained some of the best scientists this
country has every major university in
this country has someone who has been
trained either as a graduate student or
a postdoctoral fellow in Bob horowitz's
lab he is the professional consummate so
it's a great pleasure to introduce Bob
today let's all give him a round of
applause
[Applause]
thank you
Thank You Chuck and Phil for the
introduction and thank all of you
[Music]
including my wife Martha
for coming here today this this is a
very exciting time for me and I can
think of nothing better than to share
this time with my MIT friends and I'd
like to start with a few specific
statements of thanks to these friends
first and foremost to my lab I thank the
students and postdocs who have been
members of our research group because as
I'm sure most people in this audience
know it's really their efforts their
insights and their accomplishments that
have been recognized I thank my
colleagues in the Department of Biology
his colleagues have provided a
spectacularly supportive environment and
have fostered my growth as an
independent scientist and their help
their friendship remains a major force
behind my scientific efforts I
particularly thank Boris megasonic who
hired me and also my other ex and
current department heads gene brown
Maury Fox Richard Hynes Phil sharp and
Bob Sauer
for their support over many years I
think Bob Sauer and Graham Walker with
whom I grew up at MIT we entered as
faculty members at very much the same
time and I thank Sal Valeria and David
Baltimore both of whom made me think
about science but also made me think
beyond science to the responsibilities
of a scientist in the country and the
world now Phil when I first came to MIT
was 1964
I'm a kind of homegrown I came in 1964
as a freshman at that time Paul Gray was
a 32 year old associate professor and if
I recall correctly he was then or soon
thereafter chair of the freshmen
Advisory Council the associate dean of
students was Fred Fassett and I remember
Fred very distinctly from day one
because as a freshman I sat in Kresge
Auditorium as he addressed us and what
he said was look to your left look to
your right one of you won't be here when
graduation time comes times have changed
and some of us are still here in this
room
I took 601 introductory Electrical
Engineering from amar Bose most of you
probably know him from speakers radios
and headsets
he knows Electrical Engineering as Phil
said I graduated with degrees in well he
didn't quite say it this way 18 and 14
mathematics and economics and as Phil
also noted I had the wonderful
opportunity to work with Bob Solow for
my undergraduate thesis in economics the
time then was the late 60s and I wanted
to do something different and that
something turned out to be biology so
what I'd like to do now is to turn to
that biology the 2002 Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine has been awarded
to Sydney Brenner john sulston and me
for a set of interrelated studies that
focus around discoveries concerning a
phenomenon known as programmed
death why should anyone care about dying
cells what does it mean a certain deaths
are programmed first let me say that it
is not notable that cells die this has
been known for many years by biologists
in fact the real problem has been that
in order to study cells one has to keep
them alive when they die that's not
interesting that's a problem what is
notable is that in many cases when cells
die the cell death is a manifestation of
a normal process more specifically
what's happening is that cells die not
because they've been damaged beyond life
or are in some terrible environment but
rather because they have activated an
endogenous program of cellular suicide
now what about the term programmed cell
death to me program cell death is
synonymous with naturally occurring cell
death and let me explain what I mean by
that during the development of an animal
from a single cell from a fertilized egg
many things happen first the egg divides
over and over and over again generating
a large number of cells for example in
us we don't know exactly what that
number is but it's probably on the order
of ten to the thirteenth ten million
million and then each of these cells
must differentiate they must take on
specific characteristics and become
certain types of cells like a nerve cell
or a muscle cell or a skin cell and then
all of these cells must interact as
groups to form proper structures an arm
or a liver or whatever and proper
interactions proper interconnections as
in the most complicated of organs the
brain these processes of cell division
cell differentiation and morphogenesis
constitute
basic events of development and they
define basic problems in developmental
biology but now in addition to these
processes there's another process that
appears to be universal among developing
animals and that is the process of cell
death quite remarkably many of the cells
that are generated as animals develop do
not survive but instead die and it's
this naturally occurring cell death that
is often refered referred to as
programmed cell death because it is an
aspect of the natural program of
development
now as biologists have learned more
about programmed cell death the term has
been extended to other deaths that use
the same mechanisms as those that occur
normally during development so certain
cell deaths that biologists study in
vitro in the test tube ER on Petri
plates our programmed cell death and in
some diseases what one sees our
programmed cell death
now that cell death occurs during the
normal course of animal development has
been known for many years by
developmental biologists for example the
regression of the tail of a tadpole as a
tadpole becomes a frog involves the
programmed Esav essentially all of the
cell types in the tadpole tail similarly
the formation of digits for us fingers
and toes that formation involves the
elimination of interdigital regions that
are cellular in us in utero and these
regions are removed by programmed cell
death we can see this exemplified in
birds if you think about birds think
about bird feet some are webbed and some
are not and here we see on some friends
and mighty friends this is from the
foodcourt this pigeon there near the
trucks near their building 68
this is Charles River goose webbed not
webbed program cell death no program
cell death in the foot program cell
death is not a minor event for example
approximately 95% of the thymocytes
blood cells in our immune system 95
percent that are generated die by
program cell death in areas of the
developing mammalian brain as many as
85% of the nerve cells die by program
cell death yet despite this very
pervasive phenomenon it was ignored for
many years by biologists why is that
well I think there are a number of
reasons um one I already alluded to but
another has to do with timing with
kinetics and that is that this process
of cell death is quite rapid so if one
takes a snapshot by looking at a sample
of tissue and says how many cells are in
the throes of death the answer is very
few it's only if you look over time and
that's something that one must know to
look for in order to assess it to me
perhaps the most interesting and
fundamental aspect of program cell death
is simply what I've said already and
that is that there is a biology of cell
death and I think the major finding in
the field of cell death is the fact that
cell death is a normal biological
process and it is an active process on
the part of cells that die the key
studies that led to this conclusion
demonstrated that specific genes must
function for program cell death to occur
and many of these studies were performed
in my laboratory here at MIT and these
studies indicated that there is a
biology of cell death every bit as much
as theirs there is a biology of other
basic
cellular processes like cell division
cell migration cell differentiation okay
so now I've been talking about the
biology of cell death and if you think
about it any biology can go wrong and if
it does so in us that can lead to
disease and program cell death is no
exception to that
it appears that some and maybe a very
substantial number of human diseases are
consequences of disruptions in the
control of programmed cell death
for example the major clinical features
of many neurologic disorders the
neurodegenerative diseases include
Alzheimer's Huntington's Parkinson's ALS
other disorders stroke traumatic brain
injury in all of these cases there are
cells that die that shouldn't for
example in Lou Gehrig's disease ALS
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis specific
nerve cell types the so called motor
neurons the cells that drive the
contractions of contractions of our
muscles they die in the brain and spinal
cord leading to paralysis and eventually
to death what causes these cells to die
in als and other types of nerve cells to
die and other neurodegenerative diseases
let me say very specifically we don't
know but one hypothesis is that at least
some of the cell deaths in these
disorders are ectopic programmed cell
death in other words the cells die by
using that same mechanism that's used
developmentally there is a range of data
that support this to varying degrees in
these various disorders and then at
least one neurodegenerative disorder
retinal degeneration I would say the
data are very strong and if you ask me
to guess I would guess that this process
is involved in others of these disorders
as well so these are disorders in which
there are too much cell death but there
also are disorders of the opposite sort
in which there is too
little program cell death so that for
example cancer we generally think about
cancer as a loss of control over cell
division so too many cells are generated
and that's a very appropriate way to
think about cancer but it's not the only
source of cancer ultimately if you think
about the number of cells in our tissues
it turns out that this number is defined
by two opposing processes the process of
cell division which adds cells and the
process of programmed cell death which
takes them away that number can increase
either because of too much cell division
or because of too little cell death and
certain cancers the ones studied in the
most detail is follicular lymphoma in
fact our cancers that ultimately are
caused because there is too little cell
death so what I noted earlier is that
one of the major reasons for concluding
that cell death is an active biological
process is the finding that there are
specific genes involved and what I'm
going to do now is to tell you about
such genes based upon the work that
we've done here in our laboratory and
we've discovered such genes not by
studying cell deaths in humans or human
disease humans are complicated and not
ideal experimental organisms for many
purposes but rather what we studied is a
microscopic round worm or nematode
Caenorhabditis elegans or C elegans now
if you ask about this year's Nobel Prize
the major player is this little worm C
elegans because all three of us Sydney
Brenner john sulston and myself are
being honored because of studies of this
little worm this is city often referred
to as the father of the worm
Sydney is a brilliant scientist Sydney
helped pioneer the field of molecular
genetics he had a major role in the
elucidation of the genetic code he was a
discoverer of messenger RNA and he has
countless other major discoveries Sydney
was drawn to C elegans in part because
it's very simple we now know that there
are only 959 cells in the C elegans
adult and this can contrast with the 10
to the 13th in humans or something in
the hundreds of thousands to millions
and insects 959 he was also drawn to C
elegans because of features of its
genetics features that made it
exceptionally well-suited for genetic
studies geneticists are concerned with
rare individuals okay
events that occur one in a million and
so it's nice to be able to study a
million individuals or ten million or a
hundred million or what-have-you and
with some organisms that's very hard
with C elegans because it's only one
millimeter in length and very easy to
grow on a single petri dish we can grow
10,000 individuals and many more than
that in a liquid culture so the cellular
simplicity and appropriateness for
genetic studies the other thing I should
note is that C elegans grows very
rapidly so geneticists are also involved
in interested in generations you go from
one generation to the next to the next C
elegans has a three-day generation time
from the time an egg is produced at a
time that egg is adult producing its own
eggs is three days many generations lots
of animals simple cellular anatomy
Sydney said worms are good let's use
them for studies genetic studies of
developmental biology and neurobiology
and he pioneered such analyses john
sulston the third of this year's
recipients and i both worked in Sydney's
lab at the medical research council
laboratory in England
of molecular biology Cambridge England
early 1970s early to mid 1970s I was a
post doctoral fellow I was supported by
the muscular dystrophy association and
as Phil noted I came from the Harvard
lab of Jim Watson and Wally Gilbert and
also Klaus Weber and there I had studied
the bacteriophage t4 and what it does to
its host RNA polymerase an interest that
phil has continued with in a broader
sense John was a staff scientist at the
MRC he had received his PhD in organic
chemistry from the University of
Cambridge then went to La Jolla and
worked with Leslie Orgel on essentially
biochemical studies of the origin of
life and came back to work with Sydney
to focus on the neural chemistry of C
elegans so all three of us were
interested in the worm and in fact all
three of us were really very much
interested and maintained a strong
interest in the nervous system this is
the worm the worm comes in two sexes the
lower one is a male the top one is not
it is a hermaphrodite it's essentially a
female who's gonna add for a brief
period of time forgets and make sperm
okay that has various experimental
advantages but I won't go into that
right now
Oh this image shows photographs taken by
john sulston and diagrams that I drew
when I arrived in Cambridge that
Cambridge John had just discovered that
by observing living C elegans using
nomarski optics under the light
microscope he could see individual cells
and follow them as they divided and
here's an image from a paper John and I
did if you look at either of these cells
P 9 and P 10 here's a time course each
of them undergoes the process of mitosis
dividing to make two daughter cells
watching life well this was pretty
amazing you could follow these cells and
then follow what they what their
descendants did and they would go on and
divide
and so you could follow a cell and its
daughters and its daughters and so on
and so forth and for example these two
cells p9 and p10 they went on and
divided as shown here to generate
ultimately six descendants each in a
very short order of time so in talking
about it John and I decided that it
should be possible to determine every
cell division that occurred at least
during larval development after hatching
in this animal and with the added
efforts of Judith Kimball who was a
graduate student with David Hirsch and
Boulder and she was interested in gone
an old development we did exactly that
John and I published the complete
description of the non gonna dopest
embryonic cell lineages of C elegans in
1977 and two years later Judith Kimball
and David Hirsch published the go nettle
lineages thereby bringing the post
embryonic lineage to completion John
then closed the loop he studied the egg
and followed that first fertilized cell
fertilized egg cell as it divided and
divided ultimately to make the larva now
this was hard let me just tell you that
this is if you picture a bowl of grapes
with about 550 grapes and your
assignment is to watch all 550 is
somebody standing there shaking the bowl
that's essentially what John did so my
part was easy John did the hard part and
he did it completely and that led to
this which is the complete cell lineage
of the C elegans format Fredette we also
have the male looks a little bit
different starting with the
single-celled fertilized egg divides to
make two divides again so on and so
forth y axis is y and that's the
developmental origin of all 959 nuclei
that are found in the adult this pattern
and the corresponding pattern of the
fates of these cells is essentially
invariant from animal to animal there is
enormous biologic information in the
cell lineage but I won't go into that to
say today except to say that the
knowledge of the cell lineage has made
possible via
analysis of the mechanisms responsible
for the development of this animal at
the level of resolution of single cells
now in addition to the 959 cells that
are found in the adult this cell lineage
generates another 131 cells not found in
the adult reason they undergo programmed
cell death the cell deaths occur at
different points in the lineage here we
look at the development of the feeding
organ the pharynx and basically you find
that the cell deaths occur at different
times different points in the lineage
and with nearest relatives varying quite
substantially or the sister cells when
you look at these deaths what you see
again using nomarski optics is most
obvious here this flat disc like
appearance is a cell in the throes of
death and later that cell goes away no
sign of it can be seen looking at the
deaths with an electron microscope they
have specific ultra structural features
most obvious here is the electron
density of this dying cell there are
other features as well which told us
that these deaths look like a process
that had been defined in pathological
specimens from human patients of cells
that were dying and were called the
process was called apatow --ss so
programmed cell death and C elegans is
similar to mammalian apatow secede is
pronounced in any of a variety of ways
so what we decided then was that since
cells die in a specific morphological
set through a specific set of
morphological set of events at different
times in different places in the lineage
that we could think about programmed
cell death as a cell fate no different
from any other fate like differentiating
into a gut cell or a serotonergic nerve
cell or whatever it happens to be and if
that's true then we postulated there
ought to be genes that control that fate
the control
decision should cells live or die and
that having made the decision to die
should carry out that process of death
and so what we did was look for identify
and characterize such genes and those
studies led to the definition of a
genetic pathway as outlined here this
pathway consists of essentially four
sequential steps the first step is a
decision step every cell in the body has
to decide I will live or I will die by
killing myself the second step is the
killing step itself that's what
generates the corpse
the third step basically is getting rid
of the body
it's a process of engulfment whereby the
dead cell is removed from the animal and
the fourth step is eliminating the
debris of that cellular corpse let me
briefly tell you about these steps some
years ago
hillary Ellis shown here and chon desai
shown here both his graduate students in
the lab identified two genes with
functions needed for cells to die by
program cell death these genes are
called said three cd4 cell death
abnormal said three and said four and if
either of these genes is inactivated
essentially all of the cells that should
die instead live and it was this finding
that said that programmed cell death is
an active biologic process then Janine
you on as a graduate student performed
so-called genetic mosaic analyses asking
the question in what cells must these
genes act in order for death to occur
and the answer was in those cells that
are going to die conclusion program cell
death is at least to this extent a
process of cellular suicide
John ye and another graduate student
scheisse ham then worked together to
clone and molecular Li characterize
these genes and what they found is that
first these two killer genes that we
have said for first said three looks
similar to a human protein known as ice
interleukin-1 beta converting enzyme a
protein that had been purified by two
pharmaceutical companies interested in
human inflammatory disease and this
information told us something about said
three because they had shown that ice
acted as a protease an enzyme that
cleaves other proteins suggesting to us
that said three kills by acting as a
protease and ding shoe in the lab
confirmed that and also suggesting that
since there was a human counterpart that
ice or other said three ice like
proteins may well play a comparable role
in the process of programmed cell death
apatow --ss in humans and there has now
been much evidence supporting that the
second gene said four also has a human
counterpart identified through
biochemical studies done by Sheldon Wang
in Dallas Texas biochemical studies in
which he was a saying in a test tube the
process of program cell death and found
an activity that activated this process
and it turned out to look like said for
which we had already described the third
C elegans gene that plays a key role in
this core killing part of programmed
cell death is known as said nine and
said nine is different because whereas
said three and said for our killers said
nine is a protector it keeps cells alive
said nine was discovered by graduate
student Ron Ellis and characterized
molecularly by graduate student Michael
hand Gardner and what Michael found was
it said nine also looked like a human
protein this one
that had been isolated because of its
involvement in cancer a protein known as
bcl-2 where bc l stands for b-cell
lymphoma
bcl-2 is a proto-oncogene causally
responsible for follicular lymphoma it's
what I referred to earlier
okay so we have said nine said four and
said three and shy ahem analyzed through
genetics the interactions amongst these
genes and defined the core genetic
pathway for programmed cell death as
shown here where said three kills said
four kills by causing said three to kill
and said nine protects by preventing
said four from killing causing said
three to kill given the mammalian
counterparts we postulated a pathway as
shown here with bcl-2 the a path one
said four like factor and these
proteases that are today known as
caspases so this is the key core pathway
what else
Barbara Conrad a postdoc in the lab
analyzed another gene angle one a gene
that we had actually studied and
discovered in the course of studies of
behavior but it turned out the
behavioral abnormality was reflected
reflecting abnormalities and program
cell death and what Barbara discovered
was that Eagle 1 just like said 3 and
said 4 is a killer we won't go through
data but you can see angle 1 like said 3
and said 4 here and the genetic studies
she did showed that although it was a
killer it was different from said 3 and
said 4 because instead of acting were
said 3 and said 4 act downstream of the
protector said 9 it acts upstream of
said 9 she cloned and characterized this
gene and whoops first pathway pathway
Eagle 1 upstream so Eagle 1 kills by
preventing said 9 from preventing said 4
from activating said 3 right pathway
what is it Barbara cloned it and it
turned out to encode a gene related to
bcl-2 the proto-oncogene and it turns
out that there is a family of these
bcl-2 like genes and us and echo one
looks like another one of these some of
these genes like bcl-2 per protect
against cell death others like Eagle one
cause cell death so Eagle one is
upstream now of said 9 in this pathway
and it was known at that point that
bcl-2 members could physically interact
with each other so Barbara asked the
question what about said 9 and Eagle 1
and she found that they interact
physically and furthermore in studies we
did and that were also done in many
other laboratories it became clear that
said 9 and said 4 also interact
physically leading us now to a molecular
pathway as indicated here where we say
angle 1 is a direct negative regulator
of said 9 so Eagle 1 prevents said 9
from acting by physically interacting
with it and then said 9 prevent said 4
from acting by physically interacting
with it and that's what the genetic and
molecular studies indicate what is it
echo 1 does we think the answer to that
is it changes the location in the cell
of said 4 and the way in which we
discovered that was through a series of
experiments done in part by Barbara
Conrad whom I've already shown you a
picture of and also by Brad Hirsch a
graduate student in the lab Changjo a
postdoc in the lab and Fong Li Chen it
was an undergraduate student in the lab
and what they did was to use antibodies
against these various proteins involved
in cell death
and ask the question where are the
proteins and what they found first was
that said nine is localized to
mitochondria okay what we're looking at
here is a developing C elegans embryo
this panel shows where mitochondria are
and basically said nine and mitochondria
are in the same location so said nine is
in mitochondria they further showed that
said four is also in mitochondria and
remember I've told you said nine and
said four physically interact so the
question then was is either required for
the localization to mitochondria of the
other and that we could ask very simply
because we had mutants that were lacking
either said four or said nine so in the
absence of said nine was said four still
mitochondrial in the absence of said
four was said nine still mitochondrial
again without going through details the
answer was said for localization depends
upon said nine and in the absence of
said nine you see a very different
localization pattern
here's said four normally here is said
four without said nine and where it is
is instead of mitochondria it's located
around the nucleus in a perinuclear way
a series of studies that went from here
led us to the model that's shown here
and that is that this eggl one protein
this killer protein what it does is it
interacts with said nine on the
mitochondrion displacing or at least
causing the release of said four and the
translocation of said four to the
nucleus allowing set for it to be active
and thereby activate said three and
cause programmed cell death okay so
that's the basic model that is our core
pathway for programmed cell death what i
want to do now is to turn quickly to the
next step in this pathway the step of
engulfment when a cell
by program cell death it is swallowed
and destroyed by another cell
we have analyzed that process in much
the same way as we've analyzed the
killing process I won't tell you how we
got there but here's where we got there
are two parallel and partially redundant
pathways that lead to the engulfment of
cell corpses there are three genes that
act in the order said seven one six in
one pathway and four genes that have
been identified that act in the order to
five twelve together in ten in the
second pathway these two pathways appear
to be involved in the communication
between the dying cell and the cell that
is swallowing it signal transduction
pathways in one case what we believe is
going on is that the dying cell uses
said seven which encodes a protein of a
family known as ABC transporters to
basically put on its surface a signal
that says come and get me the engulfing
cell has a receptor that recognizes that
signal and then transmits that signal
via another protein and a whole pathway
which is yet to be determined and
parallel to this process there's another
process of intercellular communication
again much of it is not yet known we
think the corpse talks to the engulfing
cell and signals now via a protein
complex that is responsible for
activating a protein that is known to be
involved in cytoskeletal reorganization
that means changes in cell shape when
once so a cell swallows another it
changes its shape and this is how we
think it does it okay now i'm not going
to talk about the work that led to this
model or the details of this model but
rather use it to introduce another
question so i've been talking about
program cell death as cellular suicide
but we've been suspicious for some time
about this process of engulfment if you
think about it if you were on the scene
and you watched something die and as
that death was occurring somebody else
was right there surrounding that
individual you might be suspicious now
in fact program cell death since C
elegans
the engulfment process starts even
before the cell division that generates
the cell that's going to die is
completed so we had been suspicious for
some time that maybe cell death isn't
entirely suicide maybe there's a
component of murder but we couldn't get
enough evidence to convict Peter Redeem
a graduate student in the lab obtained
the evidence so he started with the
background knowledge that in a mutant
effective and engulfment program cell
death still occurs so the first order
statement is okay engulfment snot needed
for program cell death but Peter said no
I want to go a little further I want to
really address this in a more rigorous
way and what he did was he took
advantage of an essay that had been
developed in the lab by postdoc Scott
Cameron and this was an essay that
allowed us to look very easily for cells
that should die but instead live and if
you think about it that's not always the
easiest thing to do because you've got
an animal with an awful lot 959 doesn't
sound like a lot but if you're gonna
look for one extra you better know how
to do that and in a very precise way
it's got developed the way to do this
what he did was he took advantage of a
gene called Lin 11 characterized by Gwen
actin when she was a graduate student in
the lab and which she showed was
expressed in a set of cells derived from
those P cells remember I showed you
those piece L divisions and P cell
lineage right in the beginning well
there aren't just two of them they're
actually more than that they're twelve P
cells and a friend called W and these
cells all divide to generate six
descendants except for W which does only
v and the corresponding descendants of
each of these loony
Edge's differentiate in the same way in
general most of them becoming nerve
cells of particular types but there's a
difference six of these cells derive
from P three through eight survive to
become motor neurons known as VC neurons
but their counterparts from the other
cell lineages in the front and back of
the animal undergo programmed cell death
now if we block programmed cell death
for example with the mutation in the
said three killer gene then all of these
cells survive and they take on the
characteristics of these nerve cells
okay so we then could use a reporter
expressed in these nerve cells and
basically use a reporter that's
fluorescent that uses the green
fluorescent protein characterized by
Marty Chelsea at Columbia University and
ask if we ever see fluorescent cells in
the front or back of the animal where
normally there would be none in a mutant
effect of an engulfment and I wouldn't
tell you this if the answer weren't yes
so here we see a wild-type animal and
you see green spots
you also see expression in another cell
type here and it said three mutant no
cell death
lots of green spots and here's a set
seven mutant defective in that signal on
the corpse that says come and get me and
what do you see you see a cell up here
where in the normal animal there is
never one so you block engulfment and
you get some survival peter quantified
it showed it was real and showed that it
was true for all of the engulfment genes
leading to the in conclusion that the
engulfment process is necessary for
total cell death to occur
now Peter also used nomarski optics to
watch this process in living worms and
what he found was something quite
striking so here is a cartoon version of
what I showed you already is a
photograph series of photographs process
of program cell death and it said three
mutant this doesn't occur at all in a
mutant effective and engulfment what
happens as this process begins there's
no engulfing cell that's active and
swallowing it the process begins but
then it can regress and in fact it can
be episodic so that a cell starts to die
comes back looks normal Scotch to die
again comes back looks normal back and
forth and generally dies but
occasionally doesn't in the absence of
engulfment it looks like cells are kind
of poised on a knife edge biased towards
death usually die but not always okay
now I think this has implications for
biology and also possibly for therapy
implicit in what I've told you already
about the involvement of programmed cell
death in a variety of diseases is the
fact that these genes define potential
targets for intervention okay if you
block the process of cell death and some
disorders that would be good if you
cause the process of cell death as some
disorders that would be good too okay
now obviously we have to be careful and
as with all biology genes and targets
aren't enough to know either the biology
or the therapeutics you have to really
do the biological studies okay but there
are ways of pursuing that and that in
fact is being done from these studies I
want to add the comment that maybe the
engulfment process involves another
biologic phenomenon another set of
targets because in many of these
disorders it's likely that in fact cells
are poised on such a knife edge and
maybe we can push them one way or the
other
okay now having said that I'd like to to
finish basically by telling you a little
bit of some of the newest and that is
that Peter
use this assay that I just told you
about here oh and I should say this was
the conclusion and Gulf Minh is
responsible he used this assay now very
sensitive assay looking for extra green
fluorescent spots to try to find new
genes that might have a partial row like
the engulfment genes in the cell killing
process and what he found again by using
this green fluorescent protein assay and
looking for mutations that would tweak
the number of living or dying cells what
he found for example in a so called
enhancer screen looking to make the
effects of a week said three mutations
stronger making a partial killer into a
stronger killer he found mutations which
we call in 3376 and 3380 the 3376 and
eightieth mutation characterized in the
lab if these two mutations define two
genes involved in the killing process
that we didn't know were involved in the
killing process the first of them
encodes a novel protein that has a motif
that is suggestive of interactions with
other macromolecules and as I'll tell
you in a moment we think it's actually
interaction with DNA the genes called
MCD one for modifier of cell death and
the second gene much to our surprise was
an old friend the second gene the second
mutation turned out to be an allele of a
gene that we called Dipple one from
studies we had done and what I thought
was a totally unrelated project of an
oncogene pathway involved in cell
signaling and C elegans development unko
gene the Racicot gene an aqua gene
discovered here by Bob Weinberg some
years ago now DP proteins are known in
mammals they affect cell proliferation
and they also affect cell survival and
cell death but nobody knows how they act
by interacting with other proteins like
e to F and they interact with our B
proteins
retinoblastoma another gene that's been
characterized by Bob Weinberg and by
Tyler Jack's here at MIT so we had
already analyzed the roles of a DP
protein in E to F protein in an RB
protein in the C elegans Rass pathway we
had all the reagents and Peter said well
are they also involved in this process
of cell death and again don't worry
about the details just worry about the
title the answer is yes DP e to F and RB
in the worm are all involved in
programmed cell death what they do we
don't know but given what we do know
about what they do in other contexts
what we postulate is they act by
controlling transcription RNA synthesis
gene expression we know that they act
downstream of the protector gene set 9
and we have two basic hypotheses either
that they are regulating the expression
of the killer genes set 3 and or set for
all that or that they interface in this
pathway in a different way possibly with
genes involved in the cell cycle
something we know that these genes can
do and that's something that we are
currently exploring now the last step in
this pathway you'll recall is that of
degrading the cellular corpse and
there's one gene in this step that was
identified many years ago by john
sulston it's a gene he called nuke 1
possibly a bad name because he showed
that it controlled the nucleus and what
happens is that this nucleus is involved
in degrading the DNA and cell corpses
and if it's not active the DNA remains
but other aspects of the death process
occur and one is left with these little
pig notic nuclei as shown here and
that's how john found this mutant he
showed that it controlled the activity
of a nucleus but it wasn't clear whether
this control was direct or indirect and
it also wasn't obviously at all clear
what kind of
pleeeease it might be and if you read
the cell death literature there are a
large number of nucleases each of which
has been implicated in the process of
program cell death in one study or
another so Jillian Stanfield is a
graduate student in the lab cloned and
molecularly characterized nuke one and
found that indeed it does directly
encode a nucleus and a nucleus of the
sort DNA stew which made some people
very happy and other people very
disappointed but we could add this
wasn't all there was to it in studies
that Jillian did with graduate student
each on whoo she showed that in fact
there are at least three nucleases
involved in this process two of which
are not identified the field is very
happy okay so we take all of this
together
and we end up with today's molecular
genetic pathway for programmed cell
death again we have the four general
steps that I described I've told you
about molecular genetic and
developmental studies for some but
certainly not all of these players but
what I will say is that essentially all
of these players have human counterparts
and insofar as they've been analyzed
they seem to be involved in the process
of program cell death some of these have
counterparts that are associated with
other diseases for example these two
genes here sess one incest two cell
death specification have human
counterparts that are associated with a
ll acute lymphoblastic leukemia another
cancer and there are other counterparts
through most of this pathway so from
this we conclude that much and possibly
all of this pathway is conserved amongst
organisms as superficially different as
a microscopic worm and us now I should
say that if one looks at what we know
today about worms and what we know today
about human programmed cell death
mammalian more general there are
apparent differences we don't know yet
if these differences
our real biologic differences or if
these differences are in part like the
differences of the Wiseman who expected
the elephant and one looked at the trunk
and one looked at the tail and one
looked at the leg and had somewhat
different impressions we know we don't
know at all we're looking to find out
more let me put this then in a broader
perspective I think if one looks at the
major findings
maybe the major finding in the field of
molecular genetics over the last five to
ten years what we as a field would say
is that what has really been striking is
a phenomenon that I like to refer to as
the principle of biologic universality
in other words despite the diversity of
organisms we share a lot in common
worms and people and the fruit fly
Drosophila and a yeast cell that's used
for making bread or making beer there
are genes and gene pathways in all of us
that are strikingly similar and we can
learn about each from studies of the
other and that I think maybe I should
say I thought was the big news until I
saw this the cover of punch magazine
from 1882 where clearly the artist knew
more than I did until very recently and
saying man is but a worm with that the
people members of my laboratory over the
years who have been involved in the
study of program cell death current
members involved in that project members
of the lab involved in a variety of
projects today and I actually would like
to ask the members of my lab past and
present who are there who are here today
the police stand up because it's you who
are being recognized
keeping to an old tradition when you
give a talk and you give new data and
you express new ideas you take questions
bob has done that and Bob deserves a
couple of questions we'll take a couple
of questions from the audience to the
question is how close are we to practice
this and the question is do you mean to
use this information for treating
disease or to study this process to
study this process there are many
studies ongoing today in human beings in
other mammals that are drawing upon this
information and also deriving brand-new
information and lots of exciting ways so
this is very actively ongoing
okay that's that's my next half summon
her Oh
so the pathway that I told you about
began with this Jean Eagle one the bcl-2
like killer Jean and in fact we've shown
that this gene is regulated at the level
of gene expression RNA synthesis
transcription we know one of the
transcriptional regulators and basically
it causes this gene to be off in certain
cells that should live and when that
regulator is not active and I can tell
you how that happens but it's a longer
story then this gene is on so the
specific action of this one
transcriptional regulator actually makes
the decision for one nerve cell type
whether that cell should live or die for
a second nerve cell type we have two
transcriptional regulators one of which
regulates the other and we believe that
the second regulates again
Eagle one although we don't have data
for that I think that's the way the
story is emerging so the generalization
that we get from these small number of
studies but which we and now others are
also pursuing is that a key point in the
regulation here is at the level of this
gene Eagle 1 and that basically in every
cell there's some combination of these
transcription factors that decides
whether or not Eagle 1 will be expressed
if it's expressed it makes the gene it
makes the RNA it makes the protein the
protein interacts with said 9
boom-boom-boom cell dies if it's not
expressed that process doesn't initiate
cell survives I could do the 60 minute
version to that to
is it really a last question do you
think the absence or too much program
tell that if the major contributor to
evolution it is very clear that some
evolutionary change has occurred by
altering patterns of program cell death
so that I'll give you two examples
quickly because I had one up there
already when you looked at those P cell
lineages where we got those green
fluorescent cells and I told you that
some cells survived and other cells died
basically when we think about the
evolution of cell lineage we think about
it much the same way as we think about
the evolution of anything genes segments
in a segmented animal like an insect
basically the way evolution occurs is by
a process of duplication and
modification the same is true of cell
lineage you duplicate a cell lineage and
then you modify it and in fact in that
case the modification involves changes
because not all of the complements all
of the complement of that set of sick
cells that's generated are needed in all
of those different places where that
lineage occurs some are needed some are
not one of a number of modifications
that seems to have occurred
evolutionarily is a modification of
program cell death essentially
eliminating one of the cell types in
that region of the animal where it's not
needed and I'll leave it with one
example instead of two because I can
feel film looking at me for here I want
to say one final thing only great
institutions can attract people like Bob
Weinberg
and I would agree with that people like
Bob Horowitz and the students who work
with Bob and the postdocs will work with
Bob to create such beautiful science
great institutions are led by great
people and I want to thank Chuck vest
for participating today and being such a
strong supporter of basic science and
the activities of MIT so I'd like us to
end by all standing and giving a
standing ovation to Bob
Horowitz and MIT
you